this right here is problem number two
from the 2003a me too so let n be the
greatest integer multiple of eight no
two of whose digits are the same no two
of whose digits are the same what is the
remainder when n is divided by 1000 so
let's think about it no two digits are
the same well we only have 10 digits 0
through 9 so this if no two digits are
the same we can only have 10 digits in
the number so let me draw 10 spaces here
so 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 and 10 now we want
it to be the greatest integer multiple
we want it to be the greatest integer
multiple of 8 so we want this to be as
large of a number as possible so let me
put it here so this is our n and is
going to be this we wanted to be as
large as possible so if we wanted as
large as possible we want the largest
possible digits in the largest possible
place and we want the small as possible
digits in the smallest possible split
pace so let's just try out some numbers
not even thinking about what the whether
they're divisible by 8 and then maybe we
can rearrange what happens near the end
of the number to make it divisible by 8
because a thousand is divisible by 8 so
really what just what happens in the
last three digits is really what matters
when it turned in terms of making it
divisible by eight so the largest number
that has that has all unique digits is
nine eight seven six five four three two
one zero this is the largest possible
number with unique digits now what we
care about is whether it's divisible by
eight so we really just have to look at
this because we know that the thout that
1000 is divisible by eight it's it's
device it's aight 1000 divided by eight
is 125 so we're what really matters is
all the stuff after a thousand or the
hundreds tens in one's place whether
this number right here is divisible
I ate and we look at 210 just the way I
wrote it right here 210 isn't divisible
by 8 200 / 8 is 25 and then you have 10
left over this is not going to be
there's aliea this is going to be 26
with a little bit of it what a remainder
of 2 or something like that so maybe we
can rearrange these numbers so it is
divisible by eight if it isn't if we
rearrange these and we can't get
divisibility then we might have to
borrow some numbers out here but we
don't want to do that because we want
the smallest possible numbers over here
so that the large numbers can make this
number super huge so let's try to do
this so this one this one does not work
right over there let's see if we
rearrange the one and the two we would
have 120 this is divisible by 8 this
goes in 8 goes into this let's see 8
times 5 is 40 so this is going to be 8
times 15 so this works this is divisible
by 8 so if we make our entire number if
we make our entire number 9 8 7 6 5 4 3
120 we are divisible by 8 and they want
to know the remainder when n is divided
by a thousand so when n is divided by a
thousand the remainder is just going to
be anything smaller than the thousands
place so the remainder is going to be
120 and we're done